eugen herman friede weiß zunächst
überhaupt nicht dass er jude ist
denn nach der trennung seiner jüdischen
eltern wächst er bei seiner mutter und
ihrem neuen mann auf und er ist christ
das break vollends kindheit
doch die rassengesetze von 1935 die
verändern für den jungen alters er
verliert alle seine bürgerrechte darf
plötzlich keine öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel mehr benutzen nicht mehr
mit seinem fahrrad fahren
1943 taucht eugen herman friede unter er
gründet mit anderen eine
widerstandsgruppe sie verteilen
regimekritische flugblätter versenden
tausende kettenbriefe in ganz
deutschland unglaublich mutig und
unglaublich riskant im herbst 1944 wird
die gruppe verhaftet
eugen herman friede kommt in
verschiedenen berliner gefängnisse
er hat kaum hoffnung dass alles hier zu
überleben doch dann im april 45 als die
rote armee immer näher rückt setzt ihn
die gestapo ganz plötzlich auf die
straße
namen vornamen
hermann eugen israel verschwindet eine
große angst zwei verhaftet noch lange
nicht
ein grund für uns
versteckt war die täter gehen auf einer
eisbahn zu schnell
für als fahrer und werde immer gesagt
wenn es mal ganz schlimm koppeln wir
angst haben ihren schöneberg zu wohnen
dann gehen wir in die reichsbank dort
etwas vorbereitet doch für mich sicher
als hier in einem wohnhaus in berlin
das wusste ich dass der da auch ich
hoffe wir finden würden
in erwägung
es tut nicht viel gefehlt
das können sie dir passen
ich muss mir erst mal waschen und wenn
dich jemand hier findet mussten sich
schon ganz in der nähe
wir können dies nur verstecken benannt
und machte in diesem raum bleibst du
musst du mich versprechen einlöste
total nach verband das ganze fahrzeug
was nicht in der partei seit reisen
wer war der nicht in der partei müsste
man ja praktisch das heißt es sich auf
die neue zeit vorzubereiten
das darlehen soll ja gar nicht so übel
sein hört man die kommunisten haben
ihnen was das deutsche volk nicht ins
ungültig
und dann legst du ein gutes wort für uns
arbeiten eugen das bist du
entschuldigungen junge eugen herman
friede bleibt zunächst bei seinem onkel
bis der russische panzer platt
diesen moment fühlt er sich das erste
mal richtig
patton passen auf dem hof panzerketten
ganz entfernt russische wörter ich
wusste alle dosen waren da war kein
halten mehr für mich erwischt auf so
schnell wie möglich die russen zu
begrüßen
für mich waren die russen ja doch ihn
habe ich alles zu verdanken
ich wollte sie nur begrüßen eugen herman
mein name ich bin jude die gestapo hat
mich eingesperrt
meine mutter ist in theresienstadt ich
wollte ihnen nur sagen wie glücklich ich
bin da sie endlich hier sind jude jude
in berlin
ich möchte mich in zur verfügung stellen
endlich was für sie tun abgewinkt hilfe
von mir brauchen sie nicht er hat dann
ein zettel genommen hat irgend etwas
aufgeschrieben auf den zetteln für sich
leider nie feststellen konnte was es war
ein anwalt an dicken stempel drauf
gemacht hat mir den zettel in die hand
gedrückt damit war
damit verstößt
generell ich jude bin das so jude ich
habe die stadt nicht kaputt gemacht doch
erstmal die nazis schaufeln
eugen herman friede tritt nach dem krieg
in die kpd 1 kommt aber mit seinem
jugendlichen idealismus in der ddr nicht
zurecht er landet erneut im gefängnis
später wanderte er nach kanada aus und
eröffnet in toronto das erste deutsche
restaurant